gilet jaune grève contre la réforme des
retraites des conflits sociaux que les
journalistes doivent couvrir sur le
terrain depuis un an et demi les
incidents avec les forces de l'ordre
sont de plus en plus nombreux lors des
manifestations pour y remédier les
syndicats snj et snj cgt veulent
d'adopter le code de la liberté de la
presse en huit points il essaie de poser
les bases de bonnes relations entre
journalistes et forces de l'ordre
en gros c'est permettre aux journalistes
de bien faire leur travail c'est à dire
donc que quand ils sont signalés les
journaux les policiers constatent qu'ils
sont bien journalistes et donc contre
les embête pas évidemment l'interdiction
pour la police de saisir notre matériel
parce que beaucoup de reporter du
journaliste reporter d'image ont vu leur
matériel saisi par la police expliqué à
la police qu est un journaliste ou
simplement qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
journaliste avec une carte de presse et
caetera voilées des des choses toutes
simples dont on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui même ceux là ce n'est
plus possible en france un texte rédigé
par le centre européen pour la liberté
de la presse et des médias
sa porte-parole juge la situation dans
l'hexagone préoccupante
il y a des incidences tellement grave où
les journalistes ont été interpellés
avec violence ont été blessées à paris à
présent sans rappeler les forces de
l'ordre continuent il n'y a pas de
banquette
il n'y a pas tout
publicité partout dans les médias et de
l'appât de la police c'est cette jeune
homme
les syndicats déplorent l'absence de
dialogue avec la police le snj cgt
affirme avoir envoyé un courrier au
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner pour engager une discussion sur
le sujet mais sans réponse ce code est
rédigé en collaboration avec eurocop la
confédération européenne de la police je
trouve que c'est un bon début pour
ouvrir un dialogue sur l'agression de
sur les journalistes et aussi pour
montrer que c'est une histoire de deux
côtés pas seulement le côté des
journalistes mais aussi le côté de
policiers
reporters sans frontières a recensé 120
incidents dont 88 majeur ainsi que 54
journalistes blessés
en six mois de mobilisation des gilet
jaune en novembre dernier 13
journalistes ont porté plainte contre x
en compagnie de rsf pour dénoncer les
violences policières dont ils font
l'objet